[Music]
in the busy overcrowded and highly
competitive world of today much of the
story of mankind is recorded in terms of
statistics statistics measure everything
about us from our average height to our
average income they compute the number
of steps we will take in the course of
one year or the number of miles we will
ride in buses and taxis
much statistical data is inconsequential
columns of numbers evaluating trivia
measuring the unimportant fringe factors
of life but other statistics are all too
significant focusing a harsh light of
reality on the grim shadows that dog
humanity's footsteps
for example statistics tell us that
every year over 25,000 Americans take
their own lives and it is statistical
fact but one of the 10 major causes of
death in the United States is suicide
the urge for self-destruction walks in
step with thousands of those who make up
our civilian population and there's a
natural consequence it also marches
alongside some of those who wear the
uniform of the United States Army the
stories of five such individuals will
not be told and the endings will not be
happy but the point and purpose to be
made here is that such tragedies are not
inevitable prevention is possible for as
you will see the suicidal individual
almost always provides clues that give
advance warning of his intentions watch
for these clues remember these clues
they could someday enable you to save a
life
from his first day in uniform private
Philip G Owens seemed totally unable to
adjust to the new world in which he
found himself even the relatively simple
requirements of basic training were
beyond him he lagged behind his fellow
soldiers out of step in both mind and
body
[Music]
his failure to keep the pace quickly
singled him out for attention many
believed he just simply wasn't trying
[Music]
Phil's awkwardness was not confined to
military matters what do you do with a
misfit like Owens maybe the simplest
thing is to ignore him which is what his
fellow soldiers did they saw him as a
loner who was always picking himself out
of private corner and it would make no
effort to be friendly
[Music]
when Owen started a regular chain of
visits to the dispensary the men in his
platoon nodded knowingly and said that
figures I don't know what it is but I
get these headaches not I can't stand
yeah I know all about the headaches
you've been riding the sick book pretty
good
Owens pretty good I haven't been riding
this sick book sometimes my head feels
like it's gonna explode I don't know
what to do okay okay
go out in the hall and wait the doctor
will see you in a little while his
fellow soldiers were an unsympathetic
audience they felt that if good
wholesome army Chow wasn't up to Owens
higher standards well that was just too
bad and if he was too delicate to sleep
on an army cot tough Owens apparent lack
of interest his seeming indifference to
his surroundings his apparent
unwillingness to make any effort to get
along inevitably led to further
difficulties good throwing position
ready position put your finger in the
full ring forget your target downrange
Oh pan whoa throw the grenade training
trainee get rid of like grenade trainee
get rid of their grenade don't defeat
trainees move on
about training you move out
Owens get over here I watched you from
the tower can't you do anything right
I'm turning you in
what's the trouble Owens I don't know
sir
I try to do things right but nothing
seems to work
I don't know he's not trying take a look
at him sir I've spoken to him time and
again about his appearance he doesn't
shave or take care of his clothes or
anything I do try these headaches he's
just trying to work a deal sir I know
about these headaches you've been on
sick call several times and they haven't
found anything wrong with you I'm not
sure you just got to pull yourself
together that's all there is to it
sir I don't want to make any trouble
sometimes I feel so bad I don't know
what to do that stupid talk pull
yourself together
act like a man
something new has been added to Owens
torrent of troubles a suggestion of
suicide it has been labeled as stupid
talk and perhaps it is for isn't it true
that if they talk about it they never do
it
[Music]
Sandy Koufax
Sandy Koufax on the man with the Golden
Arm oh boy well time for lights out now
gotta get your rest now ciao
let's go beddy-bye portrait of a man
deep in depression restless apathetic
neglectful of appearance indifferent to
environment a man alone in a crowd
isolated in maladjusted opening his
mouth only to complain of headaches to
confess his own helplessness and oh yes
to announce that he is contemplating
self-destruction does he really need
help or would a swift kick straighten
him out it's a little late for
conjecture for Phil Owens has found a
solution to his problems a solution that
waits patiently under a fold in his
blanket
[Music]
[Music]
the Sikh you should not be surprised to
discover that olan's is not in his sack
for Owens desperation has been announced
in many ways his inability to adjust his
drift into isolation his loss of
appetite his insomnia his growing
depression they were all clear signs
they were all clues and an experienced
eye could have seen that they added up
to something more than absence without
official leave that they predicted an
act of desperate finality no it is not
true that if they talk about it they
never do it a suicidal threat
particularly when accompanied by
insomnia loss of appetite complaints of
illness and other indications of deep
depression should never be ignored
picture of a confident capable army
instructor his name is Chris Warren and
the external image he presents to the
world is one that many could envy but
the brightly polished exterior is only a
lid held tight on a simmering caldron
though he doesn't show it Chris Warren
is a man under considerable pressure
problem number one money he spends too
much of it and then saddles himself with
high interest loans that take huge bites
out of his paycheck
problem number two an irresponsible
immature wife who lacks the discipline
and restraint that could help Chris to
work his way out of his difficulty
tonight I'm tired of being alone all the
time I wasn't crazy about getting a
second job either lil but I got I got
the money to pay these bills
someplace don't blame me it's not my
fault I'm doing the best I can right lil
nobody's blaming you I know what I've
got to do I know what I'm going to do
what's that honey never mind
Chris reacts to her threat with smiling
good nature and then follows up with a
hurt puppy-dog expression but each
attitude only increases her irritation
and contempt and strengthens her
determination
problem number three a very serious
illness which strikes his daughter still
for her sake he maintains the image the
smile the confidence
[Music]
but then comes a blow that catches him
right on the button verification for his
own disillusioned eyes of the fact that
his wife is running around with other
men men with fat wallets and trim
automobiles
the pressure now has increased to a
point beyond containment cracks begin to
show
the image of a confident cheerful
soldiers starts to come apart at the
seams sudden excessive drinking sudden
neglect of appearance sudden despondency
these are the first clues his friends
are aware of the dramatic change but
avoid involvement thinking perhaps that
he'll get back to normal with a little
time but Chris Warren is headed down not
up and is gaining momentum rapidly he is
now careless and neglectful of his work
sinking into a deep pool of self-pity he
begins to feel that the world and his
superiors are all against him we're late
for class this morning Warren that's the
second time this week I know I ran into
a little traffic and I I'm sorry yeah I
know you're sorry but if you don't snap
out of it you're gonna find yourself in
big trouble I do my work you don't have
to lean on me no you don't your works
been sloppy and you're on the phone with
your wife all day and you walk around
here looking like an unmade bed look at
yourself
I've had some pretty bad personal
problems lately and I I guess I oughta
talk to somebody about them I maybe I'll
see the chaplain you see anybody you
like but I'm telling you this if you
don't shape up in a hurry I'm turning
you into the old man now you remember
that as his problems mount Chris Warren
becomes correspondingly less able to
cope with them the internal pressure
continues to build higher and higher
alcohol temporarily minimizes the
significance of his problems
but it also moves him closer to disaster
[Music]
women do it every time stop one for the
road huh I got to get back to the post
[Music]
keep it and now he makes his most
serious mistake
[Music]
hey Sarge
never tell police please sir it was
unintentional my wife's been running
around with another man I'm sorry one
the case is out of my hands sir
my records been good up till now not
recently you used to be one of our best
non comes but the reports I've gotten
from the sergeant here and from others
lately have not been good sir I've got
trouble I can't pay my bills I can't
take any more trouble
your offence is currently under
investigation warrant the outcome of
that investigation will determine how
this matter is settled
that's all warrant sergeant take this
man back to his quarters dismissed Chris
Warren is now reduced to the silence of
desperation a desperation that flashed
many unseen danger signals and shouted
many unheard cries for help
portrait of a man who's normally bright
and confident exterior belied the fact
that he too could be overwhelmed by
troubled but it was all there the
extreme change of behavior patterns the
drinking the loss of efficiency the
inability to cope with family and
professional problems the physical
deterioration all clues predicting
disaster
[Music]
never assume that an individual
exhibiting the clues shown by Chris
Warren will just suddenly snap out of it
by directing him to professional help
you may avoid a tragedy this young lady
is Laura Benson specialist for Women's
Army Corps Laura is the new x-ray
technician in the post hospital there
that's all we can do right now
the results of your x-ray will be sent
to you doctor since Laura is pleasant
pretty and friendly personal overtures
from the male population are inevitable
in fact she sometimes seems to invite
them but when they come a reaction is
startling Oh what is it could you take
over for me for an hour or so Phillips
has to go back to his company for
training oh yeah
anything you say anything at all
anything well you just aim it well how
about a date Saturday night oh I'm
afraid not my cousin is coming in from
Philadelphia and I'll be tied up most of
the weekend leave me alone okay okay
anything you say just don't get
hysterical I know what you want I know
Laura's relationships with all her
friends and co-workers they're surface
Affairs only any attempt at closer
contact brings a violent overreaction
even an innocuous guest at a nearby
table triggers her sensitivity
Laura you get yourself all upset about
nothing wanted to take it easy they're
probably laughing some joke then she
meets Roy
mild mannered passes and undemanding roy
seems made-to-order for her needs
laura has found her ideal man and she
holds tight
but the snug security she derives from a
union in which she is easily the
dominant force is not to continue for
long on the 22nd of August you know how
things are I suppose you'll be like the
rest of the fellas forget all about me
as soon as you get overseas no I I won't
forget about you or you won't write to
me I know all right
don't worry about it I will write why
are you sure of course honey
Laura Benson who is hypersensitive to
imagined insult and overreacts
hysterically to innocuous incident will
not be able to accept Roy's departure
lightly no good there's movement it's
too dark
captain I'm terribly sorry but I've just
had so much work miss Benson you're just
going to have to take this out and do it
over again yes captain I'll take care of
it immediately Laura yes what is it now
wait a minute now look you're way behind
on these referral slips all right all
right I'll have them ready for you as
soon as I think laura has already begun
to wave unconscious distress signal
she's explosively irritable her job is
suddenly too much for her she feels that
her co-workers are unfair and over
critical
and then comes the trio of clues that
can signal deep dreary depression the
significant combination of insomnia loss
of appetite and physical complaints
Thank You Belle peon welcome sir
and you think of anything in particular
you might have upset you well I guess it
all began when my boyfriend went
overseas he left and well he hasn't even
written to me when do you leave
August 22nd August 22nd then it's only
two weeks he's only been there a week he
hasn't written doctor and I really don't
think he will you can hardly expect to
received a letter in that length of time
I know doctor but just that I really
don't think he will write and I've been
so worried I don't know what to do I'm
just so mixed up
she bombards ROI with a rapid-fire
series of angry possessive accusing
letters compelled by her own hysterical
illogical evaluation of a personal
crisis but her overpowering letters
trigger a polite response but for her is
a disastrous rejection and while I feel
you're a wonderful girl Laura I think
this thing has gotten too serious maybe
you ought to go out with other fellows
and learn to relax and enjoy yourself
more
Laura's world is toppling and she must
step out from under the weight of a
problem with which she cannot cope none
have responded to the clues that were
evident in her behavior
and without help or guidance she can see
only one way to turn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
later as she begins to feel herself
drifting into unconsciousness Laura
Benson attempts one last outcry one last
conscious call for help
never minimize the significant trio of
insomnia loss of appetites and physical
complaints but they can be an indication
of deep depression a human being in
serious need of help
this soldiers name is Hal with me he
does not top the popularity polls in
fact more than a few men in his outfit
of toyed with the idea of pushing him
off a look in front of his speeding
truck or maybe under an m60 tank Hal's
of wheeler-dealer a manipulator a
loudmouth braggart who's always looking
to con himself into something good or
out of something bad always looking to
clip the other guys the trouble is the
other guys are smarter than Hal is they
get his number fast and lately in his
not-too-subtle attempts to take
advantage of his buddies he is striking
out with depressing regularity hey Chuck
how about doing me a favor
huh yeah how about loan me a fast 12
just till Tuesday okay nothing doing oh
come on just go Tuesday what's the big
deal what am I asking you $12 till next
Tuesday I'd do the same for you I said
nothing doing now look you put the fight
on me too many times already I'm getting
sick and tired of me me how can you say
that Chuck I mean really I'm surprised I
really am well don't be too surprised
look you're in with half the guys in the
company already money equipment
something anything or you guys are small
you know that the last outfit I was in
you could depend on a buddy to do your
favor you guys wouldn't lift a finger if
somebody was dying right in front of you
man I got to get out of this outfit
hell Whitney totally baffled by the
world's unsympathetic response to the
pressing problems of Hal Whitney
[Music]
convinced he is being taken advantage of
Hal counter-attacks with all the fury he
can muster
sergeant why am I on that KP list again
forget it whit need you're on KP you're
gonna pull the assignment no funny stuff
this time why me forty three guys in the
barracks and you're always picking on me
Sutton's in the hospital and you're the
next name on the duty roster nobody's
picking on you well I'm not gonna hold
still for it
look I'm tired of being pushed around I
want to see the old man suit yourself
his fellow soldiers grow increasingly
contemptuous of Hal's aggressive but
futile attempts to outwit both the army
and life in general
then it is just turn sergeant yes sir it
is that's all sir
I pull my share of assignment sir this
isn't fair he's sticking it to me
according to the duty roster Whitney it
is your turn no one's trying to take
advantage of you
he's always leaning on me the whole
outfits down on me I want out I want a
transfer I won't recommend you for a
transfer that's out of the question if
you won't do it I'll see somebody in the
IG office who will I can't get a fair
shake around here it's not within the
jurisdiction of this office to give you
a transfer that's up to your company
commander that's why I came to see the
IG sir I'm hoping you can help me out of
this rather when the according to our
investigation you have not proved to be
the most cooperative man in your outfit
you borrow money you borrow equipment
without returning it I don't get a
chance sir month after month the reports
have come down you have got to follow
certain routines I try sir I try but I
can't if they're persecuting me I can't
do it you can't drive a man and expect
him to do his best job sir okay buddy
yeah just like anyone else
you're on pots and pans and that's it so
let's go I got a cut on my finger I
don't want to get it infected we got a
special antiseptic detergent it's great
for infections move out everybody
everybody
what a lousy deal hey Whitney you know
this isn't exactly a hobby with me we're
right on this detail together remember
he okay come on cut the chatter let's
get these pots and pans clean you hear
I'm getting out of here and I'm not
coming back if they want me they're
gonna have to come and take me in a box
later Whitney is rounded up by the MPs
in a local bar the roaring lion hasn't
been reduced to a lamb completely but
there's no denying that his big bold
gesture of defiance has turned out to be
only a flurry of utility Whitney loses
again
[Music]
I've just about had it with you Whitney
I gave you an article 15 before now I'm
putting you up for a summary
court-martial and in the meantime I'm
restricting you to your barracks but Sir
you that'll be all
it is true that Hal Whitney is now boxed
into a corner
a man in serious trouble it is also true
that with his outbursts his inability to
get along with others and his over
reactions to frustration he exhibits
clues in common with Phil oh and Kris
Warren and Laura Benson but unlike that
trio doesn't Hal Whitney have the
strength of his own aggressive nature
the energy of his own brash personality
to keep him going
wouldn't he a man who has never taken
anything laying down continue to look
for some way to outwit the world around
him nobody is going to court-martial Hal
Whitney he'll know he's thought of a way
to show them all he's not kidding when
he says he's had it
[Music]
whether an immature bid for attention a
true suicide attempt or perhaps a
combination of both Harold Whitney's
action verifies extreme emotional
disturbance it is the act of a man in
need of professional attention now meet
Charles Walters an active man whose
bounce belies is fifty years a man who
welcomes any physical challenge as an
opportunity to demonstrate his agility
and strength but this exercise is his
bid for disaster a defiant flexing of
muscle with which he seeks to thumb his
nose at the unhappy events of recent
weeks well there's not much question
about it Chuck
you get a mild case of angina pectoris
engine of pectoris we have a Cartier no
I don't think labels like that mean very
much Chuck you see the problem is that
sometimes your heart muscle doesn't get
as much blood as it should have all has
been in such good condition if you like
an invalid you're not an invalid Chuck
you've got this condition and you're
gonna have to learn to live with it it
won't be all that hard fun get dressed
Chuck your dress
with a few simple words the doctor had
erased an image that Charles Walters had
been a lifetime building the image of a
Vero athletic rugged individual proud
and self-reliant what was left by his
own set of values was a useless show
something of which to be ashamed got it
all planned gonna get one of those
high-paying executive jobs no nobody
wants an old man like me I think I'll
just sit around and watch you young
fellows take over when friends and
fellow officers had joked lightly about
his forthcoming medical retirement he
adjourned right in with a banter but
already he felt a growing sense of
isolation the phasing out process that
gradually separated him from his duties
and responsibilities drained him and
self-respect for him the rapidly
approaching end of a productive army
career would also be the end of his
useful life his fellow officers thought
a certain amount of despondency was
normal they were confident that he would
adjust that he would snap out of it
they did not know they could not see
that Charles Walters was drifting with
steadily increasing momentum toward
despair
[Music]
I don't know suddenly my life is over
that isn't so dear what there's a lot
you can do we're not going to starve
yeah
who wants a retired infantry officer
with a bum heart you could do some
coaching you've always loved sports Don
said he'd get your job at his school all
we have to do is work up a resume for it
yeah a lot of things I can do that let's
be honest Terry I can't do anything I
can't even be a husband to you anymore
Chuck Walters and invalid he'd rather
die first
[Music]
[Music]
the intense flurry of exercise that
precipitates Charles Walter's heart
attack is unquestionably a suicidal act
whether conscious or unconscious
luckily the attack is not fatal and
perhaps this close sideswipe with death
will bring to him a new awareness of the
joy of living perhaps now the fog of
depression will lift and he will see the
brightness that is possible in his
future
[Music]
there has been no torrent of enthusiasm
or joy but in the months since his
attacked his wife has seen in Charles
Walter's a more relaxed human being less
frustrated by inactivity more inclined
to smile though still maintaining a
watchful eye she begins to feel that her
vigil is no longer urgent her husband's
desperate act is behind him a black
moment that has passed and can be
forgotten
hi I'm fine don't worry about me don't
you work on that resume now should I
take you now or so okay I'll give it a
whirl no time like the present good
Chuck you seem so much better you sure
you feel all right
I won't disturb you now you go on
working I have some water um tea but
truth unvarnished by hopeful optimism
tells a different story the improvement
that follows a suicidal attempt is
frequently misleading a mask concealing
the return of depression and thoughts of
suicide nothing has really changed for
Charles Walters who still sees himself
as an invalid inadequate defeated a man
without a future his wife should be
insisting that he seek professional help
but she has heard and believed that once
a man attempts suicide and fails he will
never try again she has been diverted by
a myth and this myth like so many others
concerning suicide can be fatal
[Laughter]
suicide is not a remote rare occurrence
it has in fact become one of our most
serious national health problems but
most suicides are not inevitable
prevention is possible if the potential
suicide is recognized and if we learn
where myth ends and truth begins
remember suicide is not always sudden it
is almost always preceded by danger
signs clues indicating severe emotional
disturbance and depression remember too
that the potential suicide is not
necessarily a meek quiet helpless Mouse
he can't appear to be an aggressive
assertive individual it is not true that
if they talk about it they never do it
it is not true that an unsuccessful
attempt is never repeated a period of
seeming improvement can be fatally
deceptive for real progress results from
change of circumstance and professional
help remember that most potential
suicides can be helped assistance can
take the simple form of friendliness
which might in some instances relieve
unbearable depression and loneliness and
which we are all equipped to offer
beyond that we should direct the
emotionally disturbed person to
professional help
the chaplain the general medical officer
the psychiatrist
these have been faces of fiction but the
tragedies they have lived in light and
shadow are duplicated daily by
flesh-and-blood people in everyday life
you may know one of them today or
perhaps tomorrow if so it is possible
that his or her survival could depend
upon your awareness of the suicide
problem your ability to recognize a
serious emotional disturbance your
interest and concern in the troubles of
another human being
[Music]
you